méxico superó las 80 mil muertes más que
un número esta realidad marca la
tendencia de que el país norteamericano
es el que tiene la mayor tasa de
letalidad del mundo es decir la mayor
cantidad de muertes por cada 100
contagios confirmados con 10,4 por
ciento las estadísticas de la
universidad johns hopkins muestran que
comparativamente los fallecimientos han
afectado a méxico por encima de países
como reino unido- ecuador irán y francia
esta realidad parecía distante el 18 de
marzo cuando murió por coronavirus la
primera persona en el país un hombre de
74 años que padecía diabetes pocos días
después el presidente de andrés manuel
lópez obrador invitó a los mexicanos a
salir a las calles desde un restaurante
en oaxaca
somos muy resistentes
todas las calamidades siempre hemos
salido adelante y en esta ocasión vamos
a salir adelante
el presidente mexicano también recomendó
abrazarse en contravía de los
lineamientos de la organización mundial
de la salud pero a medida que los
contagios crecieron hasta convertir a
méxico en uno de los países latinos con
más diagnósticos positivos
lópez obrador flexibilizó su disgusto
aunque nunca impuso un aislamiento
generalizado para todo el país si
comenzó a insistir en los cuidados
básicos en agosto méxico anunció junto
con argentina que produciría para toda
américa latina la vacuna que desarrolla
el laboratorio británico de astra setas
pero el laboratorio pasó momentáneamente
sus ensayos clínicos por efectos
adversos en los pacientes que
posteriormente reanudó
ahora méxico al igual que el resto del
mundo sigue a la espera de la inyección
mientras que sus cifras demuestran que
la pandemia no da 3